I'm Johan ten Hoeve,  I'm originally from Holland.
I've been a clock maker and repairer for a last 12 years.
So the process to make a wheel is by
having a wheel cast first, which we call a blank.
You remove the skin of the blank
by filing it off or scraping it off.
Once you've done that, you mark a centre hole or centre punch
and drill a hole in it.
We use a dividing plate in order to set out the correct number of teeth onto the wheel.
You then set out the teeth on the wheel with a device which allows you to mark or scribe lines on it.
So if you have a wheel at 60 teeth you can mark 60 teeth onto the disc.
Once you've put all the lines on it, you
file down beside the line.
You cut out the gap in between the teeth.
Finally, you shape the tips of the teeth and that's done by hand filing.
And the last bit you do is file out the crossings, and that's kind of the process.
When I cut the wheel and especially
when I, for instance, cut the teeth
you get into a flow and you get into a rhythm
and using the hand tools to shape the teeth or make the crossing,
is kind of like, an almost therapeutic way of working.
You get into your own world and get lost in your work.
What people always forget when you make something is how much time it takes.
I can make a wheel in a day but then
that's only one wheel.
If you want to make a whole clock, a year is kind of nothing.
I always feel very satisfied when I finish a product or an item.
You have more respect for things that have been handmade.